World War two veterans as I said are
making an emotional return to the shores
here the organization Forever Young
senior veterans is bringing 14 men back
among them ninety nine year-old Sherwin
calendar in fact he turned 99 just
yesterday from Alabama he was one of the
first men to arrive at Utah Beach and
helped take troops to shore
George Mills who was also from Alabama
got to Normandy more than 20 days after
d-day the now 98 year-old later became a
prisoner of war until he was liberated
in 1945 and 96 year-old Stanley Friday
from Pennsylvania landed at Utah Beach
in August and fought throughout Europe
as an army scout I spoke with them
earlier this morning
Sherwin let me start with you cuz you
celebrated your 99th birthday here
yesterday I did congratulations thank
you very much sir what do you remember
about d-day 75 years ago no I was scared
bad and excited and of course we didn't
plan on it then when the moment came it
was just it was so busy you you didn't
really get this thing but you said you
prayed during the invasion I prayed
every time I ever heard the boots or
bombs blast what did you pray for
I'd say dear Lord I know you have to
kill some of us kill me if you have to
but please do not send me home a [ __ ]
in my prayers weren't answered you know
Stan yes then you came in in August at
Utah Beach yeah what was it like that
rough coming in mm-hmm in the water up
left the boat these LC T's I'm going off
and the border was up out up to your
chest they were just going fast as we
could to get on the beach mm-hmm
and hit it in as far as we could what do
you remember most about that day
exciting exciting exciting dreadful
mm-hmm scary and do you relive that when
you come back I did when I first came
out of service yeah I relived it very
very vividly ties that couldn't sleep
yeah stayed a week sometimes sweat you
know start drinking start being a bad
person you know till I learned how to
take control of myself George you said
right after landing at Normandy
you asked yourself am I gonna make it
sure is there anything you can do to
prepare for something like this well you
know all your training your time on the
right foot range you know all your
obstacle courses you and fabious
training and jungle fighting training
cliff skill in training yeah you thank
you Superman sure when you ended up
making several trips onto the beach and
then back to the boat yes they say we're
heroes but we're not heroes we had a job
to do and you did it and I simply did
the best of our abilities weren't brave
we were scared and when you're scared
you do almost anything yeah what should
people be remembering on this 75th
anniversary oh yeah we are is the best
country in the world
we're the freest country in the world
and the only way we can keep it free is
fighting for I think all of the young
people need to really know what happened
75 years ago
and prepare themselves for what's gonna
happen eight of them mm-hmm
we don't know what has happened to us
we don't know what's better mm-hmm you
know I think they said listen is to look
at history then take a hold of it
remember what it is so you don't have to
go back again mm-hmm
Sherwin Calendar George Mills Stan
Friday thank you all for being with us
this morning no thank you thank you your
service three remarkable guys and we're
so glad they're here to share their
memories of a truly remarkable day we'll
have more from Normandy in our next half
hour until then let's go back to New
York we have any I so appreciate their
candor with you you know and how honest
they were thank you and for a lot of
those guys Gail it for a lot of those
guys Gail it took many years before they
could really talk about what happened
and and it's only been in the last
couple of decades that that so many of
them and as you as you heard some two of
those guys are back here for the first
time yeah the SD that they mentioned
heared bad exciting but dreadfully scary
yeah Anthony thank you they say know
your history or you will repeat exactly
right